how about the uh the  the suit guy with the  which way do you lean you ever have that  guy he goes all the way up hits the sack  when you're getting a suit tailored  oh wow that feels like it's going away i  don't think that's gonna last another 10  years you ever gotten a suit fit the guy  you're up on a pedestal and some weird  uh filipino guy's like okay we're gonna  do the leg then he hits your balls okay  you lean to the left you're like jesus  christ what are we talking politics here  you never had that ah what ross will you  tell them isn't that how taylor measures  pants yes yes it is in prison i don't  remember oh man i got my prom suit  fitted i ended up getting blown by this  would be great if i was like i don't  remember then i just the second we go  off there i just start crying  hysterically  it just cuts to me in a cold shower in  the other room